queridos amigos parece que nacimos ayer
pero lo cierto Es que visualpolitik
lleva ya más de 7 años aquí en esta
plataforma en YouTube Durante este
tiempo hemos publicado más de
870 vídeos Qué locura también hemos
visto en hacer a mega projects aviso al
economic y varias newsletters como las
claves de la semana de patreon on of
news por supuesto todo esto ha sido
posible gracias a todos vosotros A los
más de 3 millones de suscriptores que
formáis parte de esta comunidad y que
nos acompañáis Día tras día mes tras mes
año tras año eso es algo que podéis
creerme todos los miembros de este
equipo tenemos muy claro Pues bien hoy
con este vídeo estrenamos una
colaboración que nos hace mucha ilusión
Este es el primer vídeo que en
visualpolitik hemos preparado con
nuestros amigos de Harvard International
review en la descripción os dejamos unos
cuantos enlaces para que les conozcáis
mejor Esperamos que el resultado os
guste tanto como a nosotros
[Música]
en 2018 Andrés Manuel López Obrador amlo
fue elegido presidente de México y no
solo eso este antiguo alcalde de la
capital del país que ya se había
postulado a la presidencia en 2006 y
2012 no solo ganó las presidenciales
sino que además por primera vez desde
1988 el partido del presidente también
logró la mayoría en el senado y en la
cámara de diputados de esta forma los
Estados Unidos Mexicanos quedaron casi
por completo bajo el control de amlo y
de su partido el movimiento regeneración
nacional la victoria de amlo que se
presentó como el hombre del pueblo acabó
con el Binomio político que dominó la
política mexicana durante casi 90 años
entre 1929 y el año 2000 el gobierno
mexicano estuvo en manos del partido
revolucionario institucional por sus
siglas el pri en el año 2000 Vicente Fox
del partido de Acción Nacional consiguió
romper ese monopolio él le siguió Felipe
Calderón que también era otro político
del mismo partido y solo en el año 2012
el pri recuperó el gobierno de la mano
de Enrique Peña Nieto sin embargo no
supuso un gran cambio no al menos un
cambio tan profundo como sí que supuso
la victoria de amlo y su partido Morena
en el año 2018 porque lo cierto es que
el actual presidente mexicano llegó al
poder esencialmente con tres grandes
promesas primero y por encima de todo
ser el presidente del pueblo es decir el
presidente que pondría a los pobres
primero y acabaría de una vez por todas
con la corrupción de las grandes élites
hablamos de tipos Como por ejemplo el
exgobernador del Estado de Veracruz
Javier Duarte que supuestamente robó
casi mil millones de dólares su segundo
punto era atajar la pobreza y el tercero
enfrentar la enorme violencia que
padecía el país
[Aplausos]
tras llegar al poder amlo suspendió la
construcción del nuevo aeropuerto de
Ciudad de México creó una nueva Guardia
nacional suspendió la concesión de
nuevas licencias petroleras y la
subastas de energía renovables y sobre
todo puso en marcha un enorme paquete de
política social por ejemplo ha subido el
salario mínimo ha incrementado los
subsidios al gas a la gasolina y la
electricidad y ha canalizado miles de
millones en transferencias directas a
más de 10 millones de mexicanos Durante
los gobiernos neoliberales no se atendió
a la gente humilde ahora se atiende a
todos pero se le da preferencia a los
pobres y a los indígenas de esta forma
pese a una economía reikiante a que la
antaño joya de la corona del estado
mexicano la petrolera Pemex está contra
las cuerdas y a que la violencia sigue
descontrolada Lo cierto es que amlo ha
mantenido altísimos índices de
aprobación prácticamente poder decir que
López Obrador es uno de los líderes más
populares de todo el planeta hablamos de
tasas de aprobación entre el 60 y el
70%. claro que en este vídeo nos
queremos centrar en uno de los grandes
proyectos de este presidente una gran
inversión con la que pretende
revitalizar una de las regiones más
pobres del país estamos hablando por
supuesto del tren Maya una faraónica
obra que costará cerca de 20.000
millones de dólares que atravesará la
selva y que nace Ni más ni menos que con
la promesa de transformar México atentos
estamos haciendo historia
que viva el tren maya
[Música]
cruzando la selva
es el diamante político de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador el proyecto emblemático
que dará forma a su legado una gran obra
con la que el presidente aspira a
resucitar económicamente a una de las
regiones más pobres del país Esta obra
es tan importante para el presidente
mexicano que López Obrador en 2021 llegó
a declararla asunto de seguridad
nacional lo hizo para poder reanudar las
obras cuando un tribunal la suspendió
por posible violación de la legislación
de impacto ambiental y luego cuando este
decreto fue declarado inconstitucional
amlo volvió a publicar otro decreto
revisado en el que insistía exactamente
con lo mismo el tren Maya es una
infraestructura que afecta a la
seguridad nacional y al interés público
una obra cuya dirección y supervisión
por afectar a la seguridad nacional
recae en las propias fuerzas armadas 18
de mayo de 2023 amlo emite nuevo decreto
para que obras de infraestructuras sean
consideradas como de seguridad nacional
estamos recurriendo a un procedimiento
establecido por la ley que es declarar
este trabajo de seguridad nacional por
muchas razones porque Un gobierno
extranjero Estados Unidos está
interfiriendo porque se está perdiendo
dinero del presupuesto porque es un
trabajo prioritario porque se están
aplicando tácticas de retraso y porque
no hay justicia rápida Andrés Manuel
López Obrador queridos amigos y amigas
con una longitud de 1525 kilómetros el
tren Maya conectará a los estados de
Quintana Roo Chiapas Tabasco Campeche y
Yucatán una de las regiones turísticas
más importantes del país
Esta es con mucho la línea ferroviaria
más ambiciosa que se ha construido en
México en décadas conectará a las
principales ciudades y regiones
turísticas de la Península de Yucatán
desde las playas de arena blanca de
Cancún hasta los restos arqueológicos de
Tulum gracias a ello el gobierno Espera
que este tren incremente los ingresos
por turismo en un 20% y que contribuye a
crear más de un millón de puestos de
trabajo de esta forma se ayudaría a
reducir la pobreza de la Península de
Yucatán una región donde se encuentran
algunos de los estados más pobres de
todo México por ejemplo en Estados como
Chiapas o Tabasco más del 50% de la
población vive en la pobreza o en la
extrema pobreza Pero quizás el mayor
problema es que su coste del coste de
este tren se ha disparado la estimación
inicial era de unos 6.500 millones de
dólares luego se anunció que superaría
ligeramente los 11.000 millones y ahora
cuando todavía quedan muchos meses para
que terminen las obras ya nos hablan de
20.000 millones es posible que la cifra
final sea aún más alta el proyecto de
tren Maya de México costará hasta 20.000
millones de dólares un 70% por encima
del presupuesto el caso queridos amigos
es que no solo hablamos del legado de
amlo también de uno de los proyectos más
controvertidos de México y sabéis que
justo aquí llegamos al momento clave de
este vídeo qué supondrá realmente el
tren Maya Cuáles son los principales
argumentos a favor y en contra de esta
enorme infraestructura realmente tiene
sentido cómo es posible que un tren un
simple tren se haya convertido en algo
tan polémico queridos amigos amigas
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas vamos a ver cuáles son las
luces las sombras las amenazas y las
oportunidades del gran sueño de amlo
luces y Sombras
un tren de México para México este es el
objetivo del gobierno y por eso tanto la
línea como los 42 trenes que lo harán
funcionar han sido diseñados y
construidos en el propio país estamos
construyendo el tren Maya 1550
kilómetros y los trenes se están
haciendo aquí en ciudad Sahagún Hidalgo
para dar trabajo a los mexicanos es así
los ha construido la empresa francesa
alstom Así que no sé casi que mejor
decimos que es un tren casi de México
para México no os parece Pero por
supuesto sea como sea eso no es más que
una pequeña curiosidad Lo importante es
que el gobierno Espera que este tren sea
utilizado por más de 8.000 viajeros
diarios más de 3 millones de pasajeros
cada año vale No es una cifra muy alta
pero esta línea de ferrocarril no solo
transportará viajeros sino también
mercancías y quizás Esta es una de las
grandes claves de hecho si repasamos el
proyecto y los argumentos de quienes lo
han impulsado nos podemos encontrar con
tres grandes claves los tres grandes
argumentos los tres grandes cambios que
se espera que produzca este nuevo tren
[Música]
en primer lugar el turismo es muy
importante para México y se espera que
lo sea mucho más en los próximos años
tanto en lo que respecta al turismo
nacional como internacional Pues bien
con la llegada de este nuevo ferrocarril
el gobierno Espera que los estados del
sureste tengan una oferta turística
mucho más atractiva y que esto impulse
la economía y ayude a crear con el
tiempo cientos de miles de puestos de
trabajo Por así decirlo que este tren
ponga en marcha algo así como la fiebre
del oro del ferrocarril mexicano de
hecho las estimaciones del gobierno
hablan Ni más ni menos que de un millón
de empleos llegan
alrededor de 10 millones de turistas
a Cancún pero
solo se
dedican a disfrutar de las playas del
Mar Caribe y
no se introduce hacia los estados del
sureste donde se tiene esta riqueza
extraordinaria cultural
las zonas arqueológicas de esta región
son las zonas arqueológicas
más bellas del mundo Pero eso no es todo
en segundo lugar amlo defiende que esta
obra es esencialmente una reparación
histórica
[Música]
Y es que veréis tradicionalmente la
mayor parte de la riqueza de México se
ha concentrado sobre todo en la capital
y en los estados del norte del país que
lógicamente son los más cercanos a
Estados Unidos eso ha hecho que las
infraestructuras del sur estén
habitualmente infraudadas bajo este
prisma el tren Maya tendría la misión de
corregir esa carencia histórica y
permitir que en esta región donde viven
más de 13 millones de personas surjan
muchos más negocios y empresas Este es
un acto de Justicia porque esta región
ha sido la más abandonada Andrés Manuel
López Obrador lo que nos lleva
directamente al tercer argumento que
apoya este proyecto las mercancías tren
de carga eso es muy importante porque
ahora se mueve mucha mercancía por
camiones y cuesta mucho el transporte de
carks pesa más barata la transportación
de carga por tren
el tren Maya se ha vendido como una gran
apuesta turística pero en realidad es
ante todo un tren de mercancías habéis
oído bien esta es la parte que se espera
que realmente pueda darle dinero a este
proyecto eso sí cuando hablamos de
mercancías hablamos fundamentalmente de
Pemex la gran petrolera pública que
supone el 80% de toda la carga que se
mueve en la región es decir que Pemex y
no el turismo será el principal cliente
de este proyecto
Pero entonces donde surge la
controversia lo sé a priori las luces
parecen bastante claras no os parece
impulso al turismo superación de una
brecha histórica de infraestructuras y
la posibilidad de que algunos de los
estados más pobres de México tengan
ahora una columna vertebral para
transporte de mercancías lo que por
supuesto podría animar a muchas empresas
a instalarse en la región pues queridos
amigos si hemos visto tres grandes luces
también podemos encontrar otras tres
grandes sombras tres grandes críticas
que se le hacen a este faraónico
proyecto y sabéis que justo con las
mercancías nos encontramos con la
primera
[Música]
Y es que veréis el problema es que la
Península del Yucatán está muy poco
industrializada y además el tren Maya No
está al menos por ahora conectado con el
resto de la red es decir que básicamente
dependerá de un cliente Pemex y en los
trayectos de vuelta una vez entregada la
mercancía los vagones y los contenedores
pueden tener que ir prácticamente vacíos
lo que elevaría mucho el precio del
transporte y lo haría menos competitivo
pero con todo y por mucho las críticas
más importantes son las dos siguientes
por ejemplo os acordáis de que el coste
de las obras se ha ido Ya hasta los
20.000 millones pues ojo porque el
Instituto Mexicano para la
competitividad señala que esa cifra es
muy probable que también se quede
pequeña apuntan a más de 25.000 millones
[Música]
muchos críticos argumentan que todo este
enorme mineral se está gastando para
promover el turismo en una región donde
el turismo ya va viento en popa hablamos
de lugares tan conocidos Como Cancún por
todo el Carmen o la Riviera Maya de esta
forma hay muchos economistas políticos y
expertos que apuntan a que invertir todo
este dinero en otro tipo de
infraestructuras más locales en
infraestructuras digitales o en
instalaciones educativas a la larga
podría dar mejores resultados
y no solo eso el estado mexicano cierra
cada año sus cuentas en rojo en 2022 por
ejemplo tuvieron un déficit de cerca del
4% del pib y se espera que en 2023
cierren con un
3,6%. Eso quiere decir que el tren se
tendrá que financiar con deuda y cuál es
el problema que el estado mexicano está
emitiendo su deuda a 10 años a tipos del
entorno al 8%. esto quiere decir que si
finalmente el coste de la obra fuese de
20.000 millones de dólares el estado
mexicano de evaluaciones aparte podría
llegar a tener que desembolsar cada año
más de 1.600 millones solo en concepto
de intereses y luego claro estarían los
costes de explotación y todo junto es lo
que explica titulares como este el tren
Maya nunca tendrá ganancias y siempre
necesitará subsidios del gobierno
partido de Acción Nacional Y por
supuesto Los partidarios de la obra
confían en que las mercancías lograrán
que el tren sí sea rentable en cualquier
caso apuestan porque la actividad
económica que se genera en la región
podría compensar y con mucho cualquier
pérdida concreta por ejemplo hablamos de
ese millón de nuevos empleos que
pronostica el gobierno será esto posible
pues sólo el tiempo podrá dictar
sentencia por ahora si algo está claro
es que los números son ambiciosos
[Música]
sea como sea Todavía nos falta por ver
la última gran crítica una crítica que
no tiene nada que ver con el dinero sino
con algo totalmente distinto
4 de Febrero de 2023 preocupa que el
tren vaya de México destruya la selva el
tren Maya atraviesa y conecta lugares
increíbles hablamos por ejemplo de la
selva Maya la segunda más grande de
América tan solo por detrás del Amazonas
y que está habitada por especies que
están en peligro de extinción como los
jaguares o el tapir centroamericano
entre otros Pues bien un tercio de todo
el recorrido pasará por estos bosques
tropicales incluso durante más de 120
kilómetros el tren Maya atravesará la
reserva de la biosfera de calakmul una
de las áreas naturales protegidas más
grandes de todo México y uno de los
sitios arqueológicos mayas más
importantes un lugar que es considerado
como patrimonio mundial por la UNESCO
por su parte la población indígena
tampoco parece entusiasmada entre otras
cosas porque más de 2.000 familias han
tenido que ser desplazadas este proyecto
no está planeado para nosotros la gente
común es un proyecto turístico que solo
beneficiará a los ricos y a los
extranjeros nosotros que somos los
propietarios de la Tierra solo la
veremos pasar porque no hay estaciones
planificadas para la mayoría de nuestras
comunidades Carta abierta de las
comunidades indígenas del Yucatán en
2018 Pues bien queridos amigos amigas
Estas son las tres grandes luces y las
tres grandes sombras de uno de los
mayores proyectos de infraestructuras de
las últimas décadas en México
[Música]
en cualquier caso si algo parece claro
No solo es que el tren Maya ha llegado
lógicamente para quedarse sino que
también tiene la oportunidad de ser un
punto de inflexión para una de las
regiones más pobres de México por
supuesto ya hemos visto que existen
algunos inconvenientes mitigar esos
problemas tendrá que ser el objetivo del
gobierno mexicano Durante los próximos
años solo el tiempo nos podrá dar El
veredicto final dicho lo cual la
pregunta ahora es para ti qué te parece
el tren Maya Qué opinión te genera
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios Esperamos que este primer
vídeo entre visualpolitik y Harvard
International review os haya gustado
tanto como a nosotros si es así no
olvidéis darle al botón de like Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]